situation like Nigeria I feel like
submission
you need to respect in order to submit
fully not all the time I do well there
can be aspects of submission where you
don't need to respect them it can
literally just be yes sir that doesn't
mean you respect them
but your outward your outward Behavior I
mean like you might not respect them in
your mind but if you're submissive your
your behavior will show that doesn't
mean not having a voice I didn't say
that I'm just saying you're outward
because you just said oh you can just
say yes and not respect but you can be
disrespect at the point you're being
disrespectful you're not being
submissive can I can I have an example
can I have an example of how like you
guys are submissive in your day-to-day
life
yeah yeah so yeah because you were
saying you could be submissive so first
of all you clarify to us sorry can you
clarify to us what you deem as
submission well submission basically is
follower it's like you are you're
following leadership okay cool
um sorry but I followed leadership at
work
no that's a good example yeah that's a
good example I'm a supporter I I
actually work in as part of my program I
actually support the program so that's
my day today
um honestly I feel like submission
should be both ways
in a marriage okay
um and that is that can be done
differently though
um I feel like for example my husband
may be submissive in a sense where any
decision that he chooses to make he can
he we talk about it first it's not a
thing where oh it's my house it's my I
pay for it I think and I'm gonna do the
question is when you guys disagree where
how who makes the decision because at
some point you guys are going to
disagree who makes a decision I he makes
a decision yeah I mean he has to get the
last word yeah so so you are submissive
to him then yeah oh yeah I never said I
wasn't that's why she married
wow
that's not why no matter
but yeah
okay well you disagreed with that one oh
it's it's it's hard you know because I
know like Propel mentioned she was like
oh like I just think it's a thing that
you are and you can't choose but the
state of some men nowadays who can't
make a decision to take a girl out on a
date like oh where do you want to go
blah blah blah like like it is that bad
like it's it's that bad out there like
certain man can't can't can't can't
can't find a date like they'll be like
oh where would you like to go and stuff
like that like it's that bad men and
women don't deal with guys like that
yeah that's feminine women but more
women are becoming more women
so you know how you said that um you
feel like submission is something you
just have or not right you said that
um I I don't believe that you know and
the reason why I don't believe those
because I know how I am now and how I
wasn't before and I was nowhere near
submissive but I think it was because of
the situation I was in maybe it was in
me and I didn't know that I could I
can't argue with that do you think
you're confrontational
maybe because we're on the pods you're
thinking that but on a normal day I'm
chilled
on a normal day I don't believe you I
don't believe I don't believe so I
generally I I do agree with you I don't
believe that if the right guy came along
and said look like first date I want you
wearing this I want you here at that
time you're gonna you're gonna kick off
I think that's just me I can't have a
lie this is why I said
it'll give me the like yes yeah exactly
I don't think you're gonna start kicking
off being like no actually I'm serious
independent woman like no you wouldn't
you wouldn't you'd be like okay yeah no
I'd do it yeah a man that taught you
like that doesn't respect you and
therefore doesn't matter
he doesn't respect you no oh this is
what you're gonna wear no no no but not
in that way
it so he's nice enough to take you on a
date and you're mad about the way that
he took you on a date
yeah
sorry sorry so I'm saying if he's nice
enough to take you on a date like why
why are you complaining about him
telling you what time to come and no no
no no and what to wear no you can't tell
you can tell me what time to come it's a
day at the end of the day I know but if
he says what to wear like the way you
tell me that's what I said it's not you
that's why I said if
oh this is what you're going to wear you
can't talk to me like that yeah
but you realize that that's really
confusing for men because like like we
pick up on things that men don't like
tone a voice and like eye contact and
like smaller things so when you say oh
you can't talk to me that way and you're
saying the same thing but it's how you
say it like to men that's very confused
it's not well if it's confusing then I'm
sorry you need to go back to school
because everybody knows your the way you
talk to somebody can have a different
result you can get it I think it just
came out aggressive I don't think that
was his intention his intention was I'm
taking charge we're going here that's
what I want you to wear
um this is what time I want you to be
ready by not in not in a controller yeah
what way not in a controlling way but in
a um acting in good faith with someone
not like immediately just jumping that
oh he's trying to control you I don't
say he's trying that's not that's not
what I think he just came out aggressive
but I'm just saying how you say
something for example it's not saying
I'm not saying you can't tell me oh can
you wear something like this or this is
the time we have to meet but as I said
everything is how you talk to somebody
could remember this is a first date so
how you talk to me I'm going to be
picking up on that as well so that's
what I'm not saying he's going to be
controlling if you the way you say it
may come across controlling that's why
you have to be careful when you're
talking to people first impressions
matter and that's just if that's
confusing for you then sorry I mean if
you don't like it then you don't have to
turn up yeah
but this is what I'm saying and this is
why marriages don't work oh if you don't
like it then you can no you can have a
conversation with somebody and be like
oh do you know what could that even
though you don't know me you don't know
that I don't like it so I'm going to
give you a chance to get to know me and
I'll explain to you what I like and what
I don't like it's not about oh I don't
like it I'm not going on the date no
I'll still go but we'll have a
conversation and I'll just let you know
okay this is what I like and I don't
know don't tell me to what to wear and
stuff like well I didn't even tell you
I'll deliver it how I'm going to deliver
it yeah I think you might have
misinterpreted that's kind of what I
said the reason why I say I'm going to
tell you what to wear is because most of
the time I'm not going to tell you where
I'm going to go where we're gonna go
yeah but you know what she needs so you
know what I mean you didn't let me
finish okay sorry I didn't interrupt you
though somebody else did but we just
that's fine okay I'm gonna Read Super
chat for a second guys you already know
what we are saving for okay
get is a camera let's go you wanna know
what ish looks like
send a Super Chat all super chats will
be read for the most part
um so and to start we got a hundred
dollar Super Chat let's go okay thank uh
Chris thank you to the ladies on the
couch you help keep other women
delusional and remain as side chicks to
guys like me you're my virtual wing
woman I could not live the lifestyle
without other women co-signing the lies
I tell them don't back down I need you
sorry okay Kane Kane Marco modern women
can't stand facts and statistics their
concern is fleeting happiness The
Sisterhood and fairy tales the things
that men want actually want from them
flies right over their heads sentience
what rubbish when women ask how's your
dating life question it's not a genuine
question especially in a debate it's a
brain it's used to bring awareness and
shame to someone other than the one who
asked the question bad faith alastar
Horton sadly happiness is nothing more
than dopamine high and like any drug is
addictive you don't let your emotions
control you sentience oh Sarah is bad